Jones would be the best yes Steve is
great even gone anyone just someone
ranked higher than me I don't want
another guy a doctors yep or offense but
that doesn't help move the needle no not
at all so it's for your legacy too yeah
and uh when you look at the matchup with
Jones you have advantages where you
think
size power explosiveness he's not the
most explosive guy he's very creative
with the Striking but very creative does
everything very well explosion he does
everything well I think he's more
well-rounded but the wrestling the size
explosion and uh Power I think jab for
jab we both connect he'll go backwards I
won't